The South China Sea matters for a number of
reasons. Something like five trillion
dollars of trade pass through the sea
each and every year. It's an important
route by which Middle Eastern energy
supplies make their way to the major
Asian economies of China, Taiwan, Japan,
and South Korea. Put simply, it links
major economies together worldwide.
But it's become a key focus of U.S. foreign
policy in recent years due to a number
of maritime territorial disputes that
involve a number of governments in the
region, including those of China, Taiwan,
the Philippines, Brunei, Malaysia, and
Vietnam. Sometimes Indonesia is thrown
into the mix, as well.
Of particular concern to the United
States is the expansive nature of
China's claims, and the way it's going
about asserting them.
It has snatched territory from other
countries. It's denied foreign fishermen
access to their traditional fishing
grounds.
It's made it much more dangerous for the
United States' military assets to operate
in the region, and it's built artificial
islands out of whole cloth.
Put simply, it's challenging the freedom
of navigation that all countries,
including China, have benefited from for
decades.
So what are your thoughts on the South
China Sea?
Let us know in the comments, and also let
us know what other topics you want
AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.